(swooping music)
- Good morning, Believe Nation.
It's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that you
have a special ability
to create something amazing
that can change the planet.
So to help you in your journey,
today we're going to learn how
to communicate effectively.
(upbeat music)
(tingly music)
- This is going to blow away
people especially your fan base.
Listening.
You know, I speak a lot,
and I talk over people,
and I'm loud and intense
but all of my success has
been predicated on listening
whether I'm doing it with
my ears or with my eyes.
- Skill I use is probably communication,
which I think is building
on what Gary said.
I think communication is a two way street,
but being able to
articulate and communicate
what it is that I'm trying to communicate
is something that I find
I focus on all day long,
every time I speak.
- It turns out in corporate America today,
and I teach this now,
I taught at Notre Dame and
MIT to graduating cohorts,
I explain this to them,
when you're leading, when
you want to be a leader,
you have to articulate your
idea in 90 seconds or less.
You have to explain why you're
the right person to lead,
and above all you have
to know your numbers.
You can see it happen on Shark Tank,
it works in the real world, too.
And frankly, Shark Tank is the real world,
'cause it's real capital.
So I use that and I teach it
and I think everybody
should think about that,
explaining your vision
clearly, succinctly,
in a short period of time is
something really important.
(inspirational music)
- Before a conversation,
put your mind in the other person's body,
and think what's good for them, right?
Because you don't just want
to be this selfish bulldog
that's running through life
and not thinking about other people,
and also a conversation
is going to go better
if you think about what is going to help
this person achieve their goals,
what motivates them,
what are their values.
The best story I've ever
heard for this is Charlie.
Charlie wanted to move to New York City,
but his job was in Washington D.C.
He could've just quit,
he could've just put in
his two weeks notice,
he could've done it via email,
'cause he was really scared
to have this conversation,
but instead he got some
time with his boss,
sat down and said,
"Hey, I really like it here,
I really like the people,
"but I'm unhappy in D.C.
"All my friends are in New York,
"my best friend's in New York,
"it's important to me to be happy,
"I need to move.
"But I want to do this in the
best way possible for you,
"so does that mean working remotely,
"does that mean you
guys hire my replacement
"and I train them and
it takes a couple months
"for me to go get my ideal outcome,
"which is to go to New York.
"How can I do this so
it's good for both of us?"
And they had a great conversation,
ended up with Charlie working remotely,
first person of his position to do it,
and he got a 50% raise
'cause he switched from
employee to contractor.
So that incredible outcome
couldn't have happened
if he hadn't thought
about the other person.
- So I was um, taking off
my um, man thong and um,
um, uh, and I was like oh my God,
and you were like oh
my God, he has a wife?
Like.
Yo dawg, I'm so pissed right now,
you'll never believe what happened.
I was over there, ordering the
delicious ass McRib sandwich,
you know what I'm sayin'?
And they forgot the
mother freakin' pickle!
You know what I'm sayin'?
Yes, I do know what you're saying,
that the McRib sandwich
is a culinary mystery meat
that needs pickle to
enhance it's deliciousness.
I also know that using filler words
makes you sound unconfident,
unsure of yourself,
unprofessional, and dare
I say dumb as a stump?
So what about you?
Do you use filler words?
And if so, what is it?
If you're not sure, ask
your friends or family,
because if you don't
know, I'm sure they will.
Because that's exactly how I found out
that I use the word um all the time.
Tracy, one day about six years ago,
came up and was like,
"You say um all the time."
I was like, "I do?"
I told her to start pointing it out.
Every time she noticed or
heard me use the word um,
she would say, "Ummm."
And that was my cue to
start paying attention,
but something remarkable happened.
After a little while of
being ultra aware of myself,
I would actually start correcting myself.
When I'd say um, I'd be like, "Uh um."
It was really awkward and uncomfortable
when I was having a
conversation with somebody else.
And eventually I stopped.
It took hard work, being hyper
aware of what you're saying,
and a little bit paranoid,
but eventually I kicked
it, and so can you.
And a great tip I would give
to you is when you're talking
and you feel it coming on, just
(pause)
pause, and pick up where you left off.
And eventually you will be able
to kick the filler word habit.
- A bit of a warning,
what I'm about to tell
you to do is terrifying
and most of use spend our
entire lives trying to avoid it.
But, like a pap smear, it's
over fast, and it really works.
(gentle breeze blowing)
I just did it!
Did you catch it?
If not, and you missed
it, here it goes again.
(gentle breeze blowing)
- [Voiceover] Awkward.
- That was a live demonstration
of the three second IAP: the
Intentional Awkward Pause.
- [Voiceover] Oh my
God, this is so awkward.
- Now why on God's green earth
would you ever want to do that?
I'll tell you.
Because being a really,
really good listener
is one of the most underrated
secrets to success.
It's crucial if you want
to be more charismatic,
more persuasive, and a better negotiator.
Plus, really listening to someone
and having them feel truly heard
is one of the biggest
gifts you could ever give.
The problem is most of
us suck at listening
and we don't even know it.
We're always interrupting
others with our brilliant ideas
and our feedback and
most often it's the way--
- Oh my God, that is so true,
I am always interrupting people.
(quirky music)
- As I was saying, it's often
the way that we suck the most.
Now I'm probably one of the
worst offenders out there,
but I am consistently working
on this and I have to say
the IAP is a life saver.
Not so long ago I used
it with my stepson, Zane,
and had an unbelievable result.
So Zane was home on
Christmas break from college
and he invited me to go for cappuccinos.
A little back story here,
in the 10 years plus that we've
been in each other's lives,
he had never really
asked me for life advice.
So we get to this place, Cafe Minerva,
and we're hanging out,
and Zane starts to tell
me all about his life
and what he might want to do with it.
He's very, very involved in music,
he's involved in acting and
all these creative things,
so basically he's asking
me for the kind of advice
that I give for a living.
So you could imagine, every
single part of me just wanted
to jump in and tell him what to do
and tell him what I
think and yada yada yada.
But I practiced the IAP,
and I just sat there and I zipped it.
Now, every time I did this,
and I just shut up, it was amazing,
'cause he would reveal
more and more insights,
he'd find new things to talk about,
he'd find his own insights
that were way better
than anything I could have told him,
and it was really, really amazing.
Now I have to be honest,
my body was literally
uncomfortable being silent,
so every time he would come
to the end of a sentence,
I would sit
(gentle breeze blowing)
and see if there was more.
And it was absolutely awesome.
By the end of three hours,
we had the most beautiful conversation,
and we left that cafe
feeling more connected
and more intimate than
I think we've ever felt.
So, just a little story to show
that it really, really works.
- Another way to become
a great conversationalist
is to question for clarification.
Never assume that you understand
what the other person is
saying or trying to say.
Instead, if you have any doubt at all,
ask, "How do you mean?"
Or, "How do you mean exactly?"
And then just pause, and wait.
This is the most powerful
question I've ever learned
for guiding and
controlling a conversation.
It's almost impossible not
to answer this question.
When you ask, "How do you mean?"
the other person cannot
stop himself or herself
from answering more extensively.
You can then follow up with
other open ended questions
and keep the conversation rolling along.
- Begin with the end in mind.
How do you want them to feel
at the end of the conversation?
How do you want to feel at
the end of the conversation?
What would you love them to think,
believe, or do at the end,
and what do you want to think,
believe, or do at the end?
Always begin with that.
People forget this all the time.
They just have a spark of emotion
or something they have to deliver,
and they just deliver it
without knowing where to go
and if you don't know where to go
you end up in 50 different
sort of open alleys
of conversation, you open all
these loops of conversation
that don't get closed,
people get confused,
or you end up starting a fight
that you didn't even know you were having,
'cause you just weren't clear
on where you wanted to go.
It doesn't mean that you'll
always get there exactly,
'cause again, humility says
you're going to learn together,
but at least you'll have a
sense of what feeling you want.
Do you want her to trust you
at the end of the conversation?
Do you want him to know how you felt
and that's all you're after?
What is it you really want at
the end of the conversation?
(swooping music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video,
what was the rule that most applies to you
that you're going to
immediately implement somehow
into your life or your business.
Please let me know, I'd
love to hear from you,
leave it down in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Anthony Avina.
Anthony, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and doing
the video review of it.
I really appreciate the support, man,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
- Today I'm going to be reviewing
a book for you guys called,
Your One Word, by Evan Carmichael.
- So thank you guys again for watching,
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(swooping music)
- How you do communicate authentically?
How do you figure out what to say
and what not to say in
a way that's authentic?
And what Fred says, and I
really believe this is true,
is it starts from the
fundamental understanding
that there is no truth.
There's my truth, there's your truth,
and everything is subjective.
And so if you always
start from the position
of this is what I believe,
I don't expect you to believe it,
I don't think you have to believe it,
I'm not saying it's true,
you can actually always
communicate authentically.
'Cause if you walk in the room,
and this gets worse as
you get more senior,
here's the answer,
you're not giving anyone else
any room to say anything.
And if you walk in the room and say,
"I believe this for this
reason, what do you believe?"
If you share your truth in that language,
you give people room to authenticate,
to communicate authentically.
And that is hugely important
to these relationships at any stage.
- Paraphrase the speaker's
words in your own words.
So after you've nodded and
smiled, you can then say,
"Well let me see if I've got this right,"
or "Let me see if I
understand you exactly."
What you're saying is this,
and then you repeat it
back in your own words.
By paraphrasing the speaker's words,
you demonstrate in no uncertain terms
that you are genuinely paying attention
and making every effort to understand
his or her thoughts or feelings.
And the wonderful thing is,
when you practice effective listening,
other people will begin
to find you fascinating.
They will want to be around you.
They will feel relaxed and
happy in your presence,
because when you listen to other people
you make them feel important.
- Nelson Mandela is a
particularly special case study
in the leadership world,
because he is universally
regarded as a great leader.
You can take other personalities,
and depending on the nation you go to,
we have different opinions
of other personalities,
but Nelson Mandela across the world
is universally regarded as a great leader.
He was actually the son of a tribal chief
and he was asked one day,
"How did you learn to be a great leader?"
And he responded that he
would go with his father
to tribal meetings and
he remembers two things
when his father would
meet with other elders.
One, they would always sit in a circle.
And two, his father was
always the last to speak.
You will be told your whole life
that you need to learn to listen,
I would say that you need to
learn to be the last to speak.
I see it in board rooms
every day of the week.
Even people who consider
themselves good leaders,
who may actually be decent leaders,
will walk into a room and say,
"Here's the problem, here's what I think,
"but I'm interested in your opinion,
"let's go around the room."
It's too late.
The skill to hold your
opinions to yourself
until everyone has spoken does two things.
One, it gives everyone else the feeling
that they have been heard.
It gives everyone else the ability
to feel that they have contributed.
And two, you get the benefits of hearing
what everybody has to think
before you render your opinion.
The skill is really to keep
your opinions to yourself.
If you agree with somebody, don't nod yes.
If you disagree with
somebody, don't nod no.
Simply sit there, take it all in,
and the only thing you're
allowed to do is ask questions
so you can understand what they mean
and why they have they
opinion that they have.
You must understand from
where they are speaking,
why they have the opinion they have,
not just what they are saying.
And at the end, you will get your turn.
It sounds easy, it's not.
Practice being the last to speak.
That's what Nelson Mandela did.
(swooping music)